we followed the anti-vaccine movement
for years on the program we've done a
long-form piece about it actually to
long-form pieces about it we have done
reports about the religious connection
to the anti-vaccine movement we reported
to you about a month ago that the World
Health Organization has listed
anti-vaccine sentiment as one of the
biggest health threats to the world for
2019 and this isn't a serious problem
everywhere there are sort of enclaves
where it is more serious Washington and
Oregon are examples here in the United
States but internationally Australia is
a place that is having some pretty
serious anti-vaccine problems and
there's a new report from Australia
about teens who were going around their
parents they're circumventing the
decisions of their parents who are
anti-vaccine and getting themselves
vaccinated this is in Queensland
Australia where there's a law which says
that if you're 15 or older you can get
care without parental consent or
knowledge and when we hear that in the
United States were often thinking about
abortion services when we talk about
parental notification it's a debate over
should a 16 year old girl be able to get
an abortion without parental consent is
question one and without parental
notification is question two here we're
talking about vaccines Queensland has a
vaccination rate of just under eighty
nine percent the desired rate for herd
immunity is ninety-five percent and this
is just crazy all around there's a
debate over whether or not those who are
not legally adults should be able to do
this from a legal perspective that's one
debate that exists should a 15 year old
really be able to do this according to
the law but think about the insanity pat
about it being rebellious to go and get
yourself vaccinated usually it's about I
snuck a cannabis cigarette and I'm
hiding it from my parents this is kids
getting vaccinated and it's considered a
rebellious act because of the anti
vaccine sentiment that's growing in
Queensland yeah this sounds like my
teenage years this is like the worst
thing I did
rebelling against my parents I snuck
around them got a vaccine I wasn't doing
any of that drugs or alcohol stuff no I
was perfectly fine with all that just
getting vaccinated sometimes teenagers
wrongly think they're smarter than their
parents in this case they sort of are
right I mean because the risk is of not
getting vaccinated and the the only
maybe possible downside to this is if
you're an anti vaccine parent and you've
told your kid they can't get vaccinated
they go and get vaccinated and you don't
know about it as the parent and then
because they're vaccinated they don't
get sick you might be reinforced in your
belief that not vaccinating was the
right thing because as far as you know
they didn't get the vaccines and they
never got the disease you never know
that it could be because of the
vaccinations that they got but that
actually seems like more abstract
thinking than a lot of these
anti-vaxxers seem to be capable of doing
absolutely specious reasoning going on
and I think if we can say there's some
silver lining here it's that at least
there's a mechanism for these kids to go
and get themselves vaccinated and that
they seem to be educated enough to want
to go and do it those are the silver
linings I can identify here